allez voir abb aller la cgt a publié
hier il ya lille
abhisit et lille
oui mais tu m'entends c'est patrick
mcgoohan ont séduit hier
mais n'est ce pas un numéro je me
permets magali est ce que tu m'entends
tu mangani l'écran percuté un train de
fumer encore un plateau avec elodie
frégé beaucoup de caméras beaucoup de
belles lumières ça va être superbe pour
imprègne sur ces 8 qui sera très bientôt
que vous allez adorer les amis je suis
avec
parce que tous à l'eau magri pouvons
trouver une voie pour en sortir tous
ensemble je veux pour la france parce
que c'est notre vocation au travers de
l'histoire d'ouvrir ainsi des chemins
jamais explorées pour nous mêmes et pour
le monde
je le veux pour nous tous
[Musique]
ami avec le pierrot immersif où des
obstinés sankara et voilà j'ai besoin de
toi tu en seras plus ou moins évident
dans l'état voilà plus de dix ans
[Musique]
ce soir la pression
les amis regardez bien je suis dans
disney seul au monde voilà ils ont
regardé par que pour moi la personne
personne personne personne au lieu
winnie les caméras d'irwin y voilà je
suis à schiltigheim et je m'apprête
arrivée sur in the place bonjour bonjour
olala aux fruits et légumes oil trop
mignon génial
emilie presque une heure du matin je
suis pas venu et demie s'ils vivent dans
un disney complètement vide complètement
ligne personne nulle part je suis seul
seul seul week-end c'est vraiment
étonnant par tous les fans se posent
avant ce que tu fais je suis à booster
game je suis devant le château
voilà là bas je suis à disney on tourne
de nuit on tourne de nuit ici avec la
belle elodie frégé anton un prime
spécial pour noël sur ses 8 ans vous en
dira plus comme c b
la grille tube tu tu m'entends magali je
vais te la joues jeux les jouets par le
dr evans sur les convergences être
ensemble
on n'investit pas sur un joli moment
[Musique]